it takes innovative thinking pairing
non-traditional experiences or products
or processes with what is traditional
and seeing if something could work out
and having the resiliency to carry
through because what we have right now
is not working the number one issue is
that right now today would be
affordability and how cities are
becoming unaffordable all around the
world there's so many new things
happening around technology artificial
intelligence machine learning 3d
printing are all areas of research that
can contribute to we need just in
America 20 million houses by 2025
the housing Innovation Lab was created
three years ago by Mayor Walsh to help
reduce the cost of housing in Boston by
testing new strategies for producing
housing the house that is put together
using just one tool a hex wrench one of
the things we're trying to do at Fannie
Mae is to build a platform where people
can test and learn they can experiment
and see what doesn't work and what does
work I know that the best idea is one I
haven't even heard of yet and I know
those are the ideas that unleash an
enormous value in housing and elsewhere
you know when we started people told us
no one's ever gonna get a mortgage on my
mobile phone and today we're seeing that
that's clearly not true I work with
major banks now and I think five years
ago that was unthinkable that's progress
right there
so you have an entire generation
expecting an ague / top experience they
don't expect the wolf canto Kinko's and
the facts they're back same duty
we've created an airtight security
platform to allow this data to be
transferred the mortgage business is
fundamentally rooted in 50 years ago
rules and technologies and so there's a
lot of low-hanging fruit here to fix as
we go on our mission of trying to make
the cost of delivering credit cheaper
and we can do that then the cost of
credit and ultimately the cost of
housing gets cheaper that's the mission
honey may happens to be one of the most
tech forwarding companies I understand
they are thinking about things that
Silicon Valley or a legislator started
to get on top of there are really
scientific about blockchain and the
applications are really starting to
think about how this actually affects
accessibility
[Music]
by working on software that decomposes a
design of a house of 3d shape into 3000
parts that are then later cut by CAD CAM
or cut by machinery and put together
with human labor with direct
manufacturing Co computers you should be
able to calculate time and cost and
materials a lot better for the longest
time individuals thought that you could
never Paris expensive solar panels or
new systems in with affordable housing
discover it not only is it financially
feasible it's actually enhancing to the
bottom line so Finance ears designers
innovators entrepreneurs we all have a
role to play the world is what we make
it we're thinking like futurists looking
at the problems that we have today for
affordable housing
I always think Nelson Mandela actually
he quoted like the greatest risk is
actually looking on the problem that's
too small and so I think like for
innovation for me means exactly that
innovation to me means aids safer faster
cheaper more accessible housing finance
system and if we can deliver that by
partnering with innovators around the
country we will it succeed in an Amish
[Music]
good morning Wow students never replied
when I say good morning as many of you
may be aware parking is a little bit
difficult in Cambridge especially around
MIT with so much construction so we have
an over sold audience today there's a
few more seats but we're expecting
standing room at some point so it's been
a fantastic turnout my name is Alan
burger I'm a professor here in the
Department of urban studies and planning
and I'm also the co-director of the
Norman B Leventhal Centre for advanced
urbanism and I'd like to welcome you on
behalf of the center in on behalf of MIT
for those of you who well I should say I
you know usually start this off again
with students please turn off your
phones and usually I say don't eat
celery during the event but if you could
please just turn remind yourself to turn
your phones on silent mode for those of
you who may be new to the Leventhal
Centre for advanced urbanism our role at
MIT is to be the convener of all things
urban within the ecosystem of the
Institute our mission is to solve the
most complex urban problems doing so we
form interdisciplinary teams across the
five schools at MIT knowing that one
expert simply is not going to be enough
to solve the complexity of our urban
challenges today's topic affordable
housing is one such complex topic that
needs a lot more investigation and this
hopefully is an event where we can look
locally at the Boston issues but also
think of this in the context of the
global and even the national affordable
housing problem and I only point that
out because as you walked in you walked
through and that
submission that our Center recently put
on as part of a biennial theme about
global affordable housing or what we
call housing plus and what that means we
looked at many locations around the
world I invite you to spend some time
down in the lobby looking at the case
studies while you're here and some of
the videos that are also on the wall of
running they're up and running so and if
you're interested please speak to any of
the center staff members who are hosting
the event outside or myself if you
happen to catch me out there
our next biennial theme I wanted to
mention is called equitable resilience
and I know everyone who's local is now
about to jump out of their seats because
this is a topic Boston cares deeply
about what does resilience mean in the
sense of equitability for all citizens
we will spend the next two years working
on this with faculty across MIT and the
point of this is to really look at what
does resilience mean when you're
fortifying a city whether it's for heat
or flooding or coastal resilience or
social resilience what does it mean to
have equitability for all citizens not
just building flood walls in the
wealthiest parts of cities to protect
people who have many of their own
resources to either move or find safety
if you're interested locally I know
there's a lot of Cambridge folks there's
a lot of other cities here that are
represented here in the Boston region if
you're interested in getting involved in
equitable resilience this is just
starting and please please find me if
you'd like to get involved we want to
work with communities locally and we
will so you could be the first ones in
and help us build the program now I want
to mention just one more thing which is
downstairs represents our international
view of affordable housing in some of
the work we've done over the last
several years today we're really make
you'd shift into not just the United
States but here locally in the Boston
region and I'd like to welcome our the
sponsor of today's event Fannie Mae to
MIT they brought a lot of people from
Fannie Mae and they're gonna work with
us they worked with us on this program
for a number of months and we think it's
a very thoughtful program and it's well
balanced on a number of topics that
we're going to present we'd also like to
extend a warm welcome to all of you from
the region who have given up your day
there's a lot going on here the mayor's
conference wrapping up and those of you
who are on the frontlines of affordable
housing this is a very difficult serious
deep deep problem in communities around
the region today is organized in a it's
not a typical academic kind of
presentation format we're going to panel
discussions there'll be a few small
videos in a couple of very short
presentations but largely it's a
conversational format where you can get
involved also in some of the
question-and-answer sessions we're gonna
really just focus in on what is housing
an affordable affordability mean for the
Boston area
the first panel is going to look at
Boston specifically as we explore what's
behind the supply crisis we all may have
our opinions about this but our experts
hope to dive a little bit deeper into
this later in the morning we're going to
hear about it technology innovations
advancements in different kinds and
forms of technology that will help
hopefully the affordability issue it
will be sort of followed by this future
focused panels so we have three panels
we're gonna have a few minutes of Q&A
after each panel and I would ask that
you please participate it always makes
an event better when we have some
audience participation and if I have to
what I would do in a classroom setting
I would like to prod you I will ask you
I will just I'll just jump in and I'll
say please jump in
our moderators are going to introduce
the panelists so this may be the last
time you see me here unless I feel a
need to jump in and interrupt to get
some more interaction so again I want to
thank you and I'm going to introduce the
keynote in a minute but but first before
I do that I'd like to introduce somebody
who's going to also welcome you here the
other thing I want to mention is there's
little breaks in between the panels
where we're gonna have five-minute
vignettes so it's a little bit less
formal than academic setting panels
five-minute vignette panel five-minute
vignette where someone's going to share
their research here in a different sort
of format so it'll be a nice sort of
give-and-take
so before I introduce our keynote I'd
like to invite up the president and CEO
of Fannie Mae Tim my appleís who is
going to welcome you on behalf of Fannie
Mae Tim
[Applause]
Thank You Alan
it's great to be back here at MIT at
Fannie Mae we have a number of
relationships with with MIT truly a
great institution and it's terrific to
be here today with you all and it's
particularly a pleasure to be here
sponsoring this program with the Center
for advanced urbanism we're really quite
appreciative of all the terrific work
that you all are doing at Fannie Mae
we're really dedicated to expanding
affordable sustainable homeownership and
rental housing in the United States and
it's truly an exciting time to be in
housing in America there's so much going
on in terms of transformation of the
housing markets in the housing finance
system we're seeing things like slow
very paper-based processes giving way to
new digital processes that are really I
think going to radically change how we
go about financing housing in the United
States we have things like automation
artificial intelligence big data all
these things are changing the way we
think about housing and housing finance
at the same time there are new design
principles and techniques materials
around housing itself including
prefabrication things like 3d printing
it was fabulous I was in Austin a few
weeks ago and saw the first permitted 3d
printed house in the United States and
really remarkable you can see how the
world's gonna change there's some very
significant fundamental ways our housing
markets in the wake of the great
financial crisis have been come stronger
and safer and that's all very good but
all these promising developments are
against a backdrop of a very significant
challenge that we're seeing in the
country in many American communities
housing affordability has really become
a crisis for many people it's a crisis
that's driven by legal financial
regulatory and economic currents that
have been in play for quite a long time
but now we're really seeing them
manifest
themselves and all this is taking place
within a legacy housing system we have a
system that was really designed to need
to meet the needs of the greatest
generation but now as being a challenge
to meet the needs of generations x and y
and z and as we emerge from the
financial crisis for example mortgages
became much safer and more sustainable
and yet we have to do more to give
greater access to credit to creditworthy
borrowers today's borrowers of today's
renters come for a much more diverse set
of backgrounds both economically and
demographically more than any other in
the history of our country and many are
burdened by things that we haven't seen
in the past there's their burden by
student debt many of them are working in
a gig economy it's very difficult they
are essentially cobbling together
careers for themselves
technology and innovation are opening up
new mortgage and rental options for
today's borrowers and renters but these
new products and new thinking thinking
will ring hollow if we don't address the
fundamental underlying issue which is
the supply of affordable housing the
current housing recovery has taken place
much more on the high end of the market
than on the affordable end and homes
that are affordable and accessible to
first-time homebuyers have actually
diminished since the financial crisis
rather than increased and frankly at
this point close to half of all
households are all renters in the United
States our cost bird and that is they
spend more than a third of their income
on rent and utilities so affordable
housing has really become a significant
challenge in our time and meeting this
challenge will require our best ideas
our best talent and many many hands on
the job so it's going to require private
sector moxie and innovation it's going
to require capital markets that are
ready to fuel those innovations and it's
going to require a policy and regulatory
environment that
that accepts and welcomes intelligent
risk-taking and new ideas so fortunately
there are representatives of all three
of those disciplines here in the room
both in terms of the people who will be
on our panels and in our audience and
we're really proud at Fannie Mae to
share our experiences here but more
fundamentally to listen and learn from
all of you to try to help address these
issues we hope that today will lead to a
conversation that will help address an
issue that really is vital to our
country it's absolutely imperative that
we start to develop a national housing
policy but frankly much of that policy
is going to take place at the at the at
the local level that's where things
really get done that's where things can
really happen so we look forward to
today's conversation I want to thank you
all for being here I'm going to turn
things back to Alan who's going to
introduce our keynote speaker thank you
[Applause]
thanks Tim I'd like to now introduce the
keynote to kick off the morning our
keynote speaker is Krystle Kornegay
she's currently the executive director
of mass housing the independent aged
it's an independent agency created in
1966 that is charged with providing
financing for affordable housing in
Massachusetts prior to mass housing
Krystle served as the Under Secretary
for Housing and Community Development
where she in Massachusetts where she
increased state capital dollars for
affordable housing by 18 percent since
2015 and increased rental subsidies for
low-income families by 42 percent she
also launched a collaborative 100
million dollar work force housing
initiative and worked to streamline the
community investment tax credit program
Krystal is a graduate of the achieving
excellence program at Harvard Kennedy
School I didn't hear any boos so there's
not a lot of ammonia she has a Bachelor
Bachelor of Arts from Hunter College but
of course her most important academic
achievement is receiving her master's
degree in City Planning from MIT School
of Architecture and planning please join
me in welcoming Krystle
[Applause]
alright I'm gonna like her we're gonna
technology here which I might need help
with let's try to see there you go I do
need help with the technology don't
laugh at me Jared I hear you oh great
anyway oh they're for reading not really
distance you guys started to look really
blurry good morning thank you all for
coming and for having me this morning
I'm gonna spend a little bit of time
talking this morning about how the state
has how the state kind of views what the
challenges in terms of housing
affordability and supply and a little
bit about what we've been trying to do
to address that just want to talk first
about mass housing I've been near
probably going over four or five months
now mass housing is the state's
affordable housing bank as Allen
described mass housing has been around
since 1966 and over the past three years
alone we've generated over 1.8 billion
dollars in home mortgages and helped
seventy seven hundred families become
homeowners including three thousand
low-income families purchased purchasing
their first homes of loan 2.2 billion
dollars to developers affordable housing
many of whom are in the room and
preserve the affordability of 3,000
rental units for low-income households
so about two years ago the government
when I was undersecretary the governor
asked a bunch of us interdisciplinary
folks from ANF folks from do our folks
from a to really look at do a little
study about what did we think the cause
of the problem was because everybody
says we have an affordable housing
crisis
but then there were those of us who've
been doing like straight affordable
housing for a long time and it felt like
there's been a crisis and some of what
we had to do through that process was to
educate people who weren't as deeply
steeped in the day-to-day work as we
were so one of the things we discovered
was that supply and demand do matter and
the decades in the 60s 70s and 80s you
can see we were building about 30,000
units
you know annually through those decades
and now we're just building half as much
and so that decrease over the past three
years has really caused a problem in our
supply and that slow production has led
to inflated housing prices as you can
see through this map I mean through this
graph as well as created a costly rental
market which none of this stuff anyone
in this room is gonna be surprised about
the other thing that happens is we live
in a in the state of Massachusetts we
have what we call a home rule and so we
have basically 351 zoning rules every
city in town gets to decide how they
want to build out if they want to build
and if they do what that looks like and
a lot of that has led to kind of sprawl
and so when you think about one acre
zoning we do this little graphic to
understand what that means the other
thing is we realize in Massachusetts
that it takes a super majority to change
local zoning rules and Massachusetts is
one of the one of ten states in the
country and the only state in New
England for which that is true as
opposed to a simple majority and when we
go around and talk to municipal leaders
we often hear we could have got that
project done but for thirteen votes at
Town Meeting and then the real problem
the real thing that I believe raises
this to crisis level is because we're
not building housing anymore for
middle-class we've now got to this place
in which you could make a hundred
$120,000 a year
and can't afford a house and that's a
huge problem for our young people for
our families and even for older folks
who are looking to downsize as you can
see the middle-income cost burden has
spiked over time some of which we were
just talking about before gone from
levels of twenty thirty two percent to
almost fifty percent in metro Boston and
because of that the the cost burdens are
really creating a different kind of City
in Boston moving to a place where we're
having you know really high income
housing and really low income housing
because it can be subsidized and then we
also had to think about there was all
this debate about well who is workforce
housing for what is middle income mean
and that often becomes a challenge when
you talk about affordable right and the
way that salaries are going today you
could be a line cook and the building
maintenance worker raising one child and
you know you're 70 percent of ami an
area meeting income which normally one
would be able to at least find a rental
unit in the marketplace and be able to
afford that no longer can we see those
things those things are harder and
harder to come by
and because middle-income families can't
really afford to live near the near
where they work we're experiencing huge
kind of traffic infrastructure problems
people are on the road longer because if
you want to buy a house you got to drive
till you can afford one and that's
getting further and further away from
the employment center so a couple of
things that the administration did one
was about making sure that whatever we
did we did in partnership with
municipalities and so the governor did
this initiative called promoting housing
choice and wanted to really try to think
about how could we get to
to produce 135,000 new housing units by
2025 so we created a package of
incentives and rewards one of which is
based on the idea that there are
communities doing the things that we
want them to do and that we already have
a host of incentives for communities and
so what we really wanted to do was
reward folks who had been doing high
production over the past five years and
to encourage them to keep doing that and
hold that up as some as something that
communities could strive to the other
thing we realized was there is a lot of
technical assistance across the state
government but if you're an immunity and
you don't know exactly what you want you
got to figure out how to do that and we
wanted to create a way in which you
could get coordinated access to
technical assistance we didn't feel we
didn't want we didn't want you to watch
us make the sausage right we just wanted
to like serve you sausage and the final
thing as part of this initiative the
governor put forth legislation that was
basically lowering that supermajority
bar to a simple majority and not for
everything but for certain good zoning
practices so if you wanted to reduce
your parking requirement in your
downtown you could do that by a simple
majority instead of a supermajority if
you wanted to create accessory dwelling
unit guidelines for your community you
could do that by simple majority not
supermajority or even not by a special
permit I talked about a bunch of this
rewarding local production the
communities in blue are all housing
choice communities the governor recently
announced we had 67 communities and that
represents almost 80,000 new units of
housing that got produced over the past
five years doesn't sound like a lot but
we wanted to celebrate it and celebrate
the communities that do that
this is about technical assistance and
ways in which we wanted to coordinate
all of that and really work across the
different kinds of agencies that are
part of state government delivering this
technical assistance so that there would
be no wrong front door for a musicality
the other thing we did at mass housing
was we knew that there were folks who
folks municipalities who could have a
plan but really didn't necessarily have
the right resources to turn that plan
into action and so we created a program
that we call planning for production
which we recently funded 14 projects
that promise to deliver more than 4,200
new middle-income housing units over the
next new mixed income housing unit sorry
over the next several years the other
thing we did when we walked around and
talked to municipalities was there's all
this conversation and fear about really
big projects people come in to their
community developers coming into their
communities doing two and three hundred
unit projects and so we created this
program that we call community scale
housing which is really about allowing a
local community to put up their money
the state would match that and that we
could get housing production in smaller
communities and in rural areas and in
addition and we did the workforce
housing initiative that's a hundred
million dollars of funds that mass
housing put forth with the goal of
creating a thousand new units over the
goal was to do that over four years
we've put most of the money on the
street in the past two years and are up
to about 750 units we've closed or
committed 50 7.5 million of that we've
got some more kind of soft commitments
coming that's 25 projects in 14 cities
23 hundred mixed income units and really
the program is built modeled
after the state's other kind of capital
Bond programs and serves as a subsidy
for communities to allow a different mix
in their projects this is just an
example of some projects I won't go
through that and y'all look great no
Larry one of yours is not fair
and so the other things that we're going
to be thinking about moving forward in
terms of how we continue to address this
one of which is really trying to promote
home ownership for young residents and
working families and not just promote
home ownership through homeownership
products but really be thinking about
how do we promote a homeownership
development product for this income
bracket that would be very important so
we think that instead of really trying
to figure out how to subsidize someone
who's making like I said a hundred
thousand dollars to live in a rental
unit it would be better for all of us if
we could figure out how to get them to
buy and that would free up more rental
units for and that would help drive
price down maybe the other thing as we
talked about earlier was we've got to do
something around innovations in design
and construction in Massachusetts in
particular we're kind of slow behind the
curve in terms of what those innovations
are and really trying to think about
what is the appropriate role for mass
housing to kind of bring those things
forth and what kinds of risks we should
be we would be willing to take in order
to see that happen and then thinking
about senior housing because at the end
of the day is all about me and where am
I going to live and thinking about
senior housing but not just a senior
housing product but a senior housing
product that really does integrate
service delivery and pay for that
not necessarily with housing dollars and
as we work with on the executive office
of Elder affairs
and the Secretary of HHS we really feel
like there are ways that we could be
innovative around federal funding
programs to make that happen so I think
that's it that's my story and I'm
sticking to it
good morning and happy Monday my name is
John Broderick I am mortgage banking
director at Eastern Bank and the
incoming chair at the Massachusetts
Mortgage Bankers Association and I'm
delighted to be here this morning to
kick off our first panel on what's
behind the housing supply crisis and I
am privileged to be joined by three very
distinguished experts who I would like
to introduce at the far left your right
is Bill Wheaton bill is a member of the
MIT faculty and has been since 1972 he
helped to develop the field of urban
economics by pioneering the theory of
how land location and housing markets
jointly operate he also specializes in
the problems of urban infrastructure in
local government finance he has written
numerous numerous articles in scholarly
journals throughout the world and as a
co-author of urban economics and real
estate markets the first textbook to
cover both real estate applications and
economics bill was the first economist
to apply Econometrica methods to the
forecasting of real estate markets and
as a principle of Tuerto Wheaton
Research a globally recognized real
estate consulting firm that works with
the real estate industry to better
understand the fluctuations and trends
of the market seated next to bill is
Sonia Gupta Soni is joining the program
a leadership team at the Boston
foundation as the director of
neighborhoods and development and
housing in this role she will drive the
development implementation and
evaluation of one of the Foundation's
strategic priorities addressing the need
for affordable homes for the people
Greater Boston with a special focus on
affordability and deep affordability
Sony comes to the Boston foundation from
home funders an affordable housing
collaborative where she served as
executive director since 2011 she
received her bachelor's degree in
architecture from the sir JJ College in
architecture in Mumbai India and a
Master of Science in architecture
studies from MIT and seated next to me
is Jonathan lawless Jonathan is a vice
president at fannie mae of single-family
product development and affordable
housing he's responsible for driving
innovation in the mortgage industry to
expand access to credit and affordable
housing across the country ultimately
through programs designed to benefit
renters home buyers and the industry
Jonathan leads development of test and
learn initiatives to address changing
market needs as well as developing other
creative solutions to support lenders
and servicers so they can better
understand their borrowers so jumping
right into it bill there is definitely a
housing crisis there are not enough
homes of all sorts and sizes in the
Greater Boston area other parts of the
country are experiencing the same type
of issues but maybe not quite to the
great extent same extent but certainly
trends what do you see from a macro
perspective as the key economic drivers
of the current shortage of affordable
housing
thanks very much I'm delighted to be
here I really see this as involving two
questions the first one could be thought
of as the problem of housing
affordability and the second question is
the problem of affordable housing so
housing affordability is why is San
Francisco so expensive relative to
Denver and Denver so expensive relative
to say Detroit and this is a very big
difference the same house across these
three cities varies by hundreds and
hundreds of thousands of dollars and I
call that the problem of housing
affordability the second problem is
how do we provide affordable housing for
a sub-segment of the population that's
very young it's very old it's infirmed
makes less than the median income this
is a social policy problem but it's a
little different than the first problem
so let me you know kind of give you an
idea about where economists come out on
the problem of housing affordability we
have three well recognized factors that
we can demonstrate statistically
theoretically explain a huge amount of
the difference between say San Francisco
Denver and Detroit the first one of
these is the supply of land you take
each of these metropolitan areas and put
a pin in the center of the of the area
and draw a 50-mile radius and then ask
the question how much of the area within
this 50 miles is buildable land that's
vacant no water no ledge no hills like
that and you find that this this metric
explains a huge amount of the difference
in the affordability of one city versus
another it makes it terrifically
interesting and clever Journal article
and he kind of misused this all the time
and unfortunately there's nothing we can
do about it actually a friend of mine
said well there was something we could
do about it
and if you look at cities 100 and 200
years ago they filled in land they
increase their supply of land by cutting
down hills and filling land and it is
true that if you took the lower half of
the San Francisco Bay and cut down some
hills and filled it in you would
radically change the supply of land and
housing prices in the Bay Area but
that's a very radical solution it was
feasible 150 years ago but not now the
second thing that's very important is
the cost of construction now here
materials are pretty ubiquitous plywood
Steve steel and the real difference is
the cost of labor so carpenters are in
fact paid almost twice as much in San
Francisco as they're paid in Detroit and
Denver's somewhere in the middle and
it's really interesting because for
decades and even centuries immigrant
emigrants have been a key provider of
workforce to the construction industry
and the construction industry in turn
has been a very important venue vehicle
by which immigrants got assimilated into
the economy so let's see that takes us
to where we are politically and that
makes me really pessimistic on the cost
side okay if we're really going to damp
down on immigration the cost of
construction is going to get higher and
higher in the coming years and the
solution is quite obvious the third
factor that is very very important is
what I would call procedural impediments
to the development process to permits to
authorizations to hearings to
inspections we have some measures of
sort of how long does it take to get a
project from you know start to finish in
each of these cities and it's it's very
important its lines up exactly with what
you would think and we know from options
theory that when you stretch out the
development process you add both to cost
and you also add to risk because you
start a project and you don't know if
it's gone I'm not going to be built for
two or three or four years the market
may turn sour and that risk discourages
development so simply stretching out the
development process means it's more
difficult to build when you want to
build and that has shown many many times
to decrease the likelihood of
development so in terms of the problem
of housing affordability we've either
got a fill in land change immigration
policy which we don't seem likely to do
or have state governments somehow rein
in the process by which local
communities
slow down throw up an enormous number of
hurdles to development all right let me
go to the second
issue the question of affordable housing
here I think economists again have two
or three very important conclusions that
they've developed over the years the
first is that it's not economical to
build inexpensive or affordable housing
without large subsidies the section 8
program by the time you add it all up
has a huge subsidy to building those
units you have the tenants who have
their rents subsidized 20 30 40 percent
and then you have the tax subsidy so
that brings their ability to pay rent up
to the market rate and then you have the
tax subsidy to developers on the back
end making it a lower cost of capital to
actually develop these projects so it is
it is it's it's it's it's you know of
course all these areas this is a real
problem all right the second problem we
have with affordable housing is no
jurisdiction wants it ok they really
don't want it they may say they want it
but they don't want it and they don't
want it for from their own perspective
perfectly justifiable fiscal reasons
local governments in the United States
provide a huge number of services police
fire water delivery electricity delivery
lots of roads and bridges and of course
our whole public school system and they
do that with basically just two sources
of revenue fees and property taxes and
in the United States local governments
can only spend what they can raise
that's not true of Germany or France or
any of the EU countries or Japan we are
the only country who says to local
governments you have to sort of eat what
you kill or you know spend what you
raise and when you give them that set of
instructions they're naturally going to
say well the only kind of housing I want
am I to be built in my jurisdiction is
let's see luxury condos
that our absentee owned second homes
commercial property these are all cash
cows for cities and towns what's not a
cash cow it's just the opposite is
affordable housing which we'll use to
three some cities say four times as many
services as that actually pays in
property taxes even families are in a
situation that's difficult in order to
to house a family you have to put it in
surprise a McMansion in order for it to
generate enough tax revenue to pay for
itself again we have a system of states
that create a system of local
governments in which this is the
incentive and it's gonna be very very
difficult to change by policy now lastly
the way the market historically has
handled the problem of affordable
housing is through what we call
filtering build enough houses in the
middle and upper part of the market and
as new houses get built other houses
kind of move down the quality spectrum
they moved to poorer locations and
individuals who are you know young old
and firmed below median income live in
those houses now I'm actually a big
proponent of filtering okay but
filtering only works to the extent that
you're building a lot of houses up at
the high end or the middle end and
letting them filter down so that takes
us right back to the first problem which
is we have a problem of housing
unaffordability because we're not
building enough housing and so to me
that not building enough housing has two
implications yet first of all it makes
housing unaffordable for everybody
except the most wealthy of us and
secondly it's slowing down particularly
the process of filtering which greatly
impacts the people at the sort of lower
half of the market who are finding
increasingly they can't live in anything
without doubling up or tripling up or
what they can afford is sort of almost
uninhabitable so there's no easy answer
here
although there are a couple of those
policy levers terrific thank you bill it
certainly seems like we have our work
cut out for us
next question kind of piggybacking off
of what you described is is to Jonathan
and the American homeowners and renters
seem to be changing financially
ethnically demographically is our
current system ready to handle these
changes
thank you John thanks everyone for
having me here today and Bill that
introduction makes me think I'm gonna go
work on something easier like world
peace or something it's really quite a
quite a challenge you've laid out you
know I think layered on on top of what
what Bill mentions and something that
Tim mentioned earlier on is that we are
a changing country and the way that
demographics are trending makes the
housing challenge we're facing a very
different one so not only are we not
building enough supply now that this may
be a temporary situation but we also
have the wrong supply today and so what
I mean by that is if 40% of the housing
stock in America was built for a
traditional nuclear family a
three-bedroom home white picket fence
perfect for a dog but less than 20% of
households today are that traditional
family and so you look at the other end
where 28% of households are now single
adults but only 12% of the housing stock
is designed for single adults so adding
all of that together Plus this growing
preference for the city is creating a
really really interesting challenge
particularly as baby boomers want to
move to the city Millennials want to
move to the city they're living five
people to an apartment now so those
demographic shifts the changes in
diversity the changes in the ages of our
country and so the household composition
are another layer onto what we have to
think about in terms of housing supply
and what's going on in terms of you know
what's working and how is the housing
industry responding you know I think Tim
mentioned a few things earlier on that
are really really important
considerations right this has been an
industry that has been very slow to be
innovative and what we're seeing more
and more so is now this adoption of test
and learn methodology you know embracing
new technologies and wrecking
the willingness to change and we've seen
that in processes like taking the $8,000
it cost to originate a single family
loan and really trying to peel that back
and make it cheaper and that really
helps on the affordable Ingle that bill
mentioned for those lower-income
families to be able to get in homes
8,000 if you're buying a million dollar
home in Boston doesn't seem like a lot
but for somebody buying a $200,000 home
that upfront cost is a lot so technology
and other things that you're gonna hear
about today are really reducing that
cost I think the other thing we've made
a lot of progress on is access to credit
we've gotten really thoughtful about
what sustainable homeownership means how
we analyze and assess that how we build
technology in the underwriting process
to allow people that really are credit
worthy and can sustain homeownership to
be able to access that financing but I
mean all of those things in light of the
fact that we have a supply constraint
market becomes more problematic and what
I mean by that is I've often been told
my role is to do access to credit
affordable housing but those two things
are in some ways in conflict the more
you open up access the more people can
buy the more you're increasing demand
for dwindling supply of things so so as
we think about where the housing
industry is that's why this question
we're talking about today is so critical
got great access people can buy homes
but if there's not enough homes
certainly in some markets like Boston
all you're gonna see is home prices go
up which is gonna have the opposite
effect that we really want to do with
access to credit
we just find those underserved consumers
and help them get into homes terrific
thank Li thank you and certainly you
know I see that in my activities in
mortgage banking where right now
multiple offers on a home driving up the
prices we have people who have you know
perhaps financed a home at 3% and now
the thoughts of moving out of that loan
into a rising rate environment is
stagnating their willingness to sell and
so just a lot of things which are
compounding as you described now Sonne
are a little bit on the other end where
you're really working with the
non-for-profits and and frontline with
issues that are
you know very difficult homelessness
perhaps rent renters trying to afford
homes first-time buyers education tell
me with your work for nonprofit some of
the challenges that you might be facing
today and and how you see those playing
out thank you it's great to be here I
think the environment is the same for
nonprofits as it is for everybody here
we're looking at an enormous shortage of
housing the mass housing partnership
estimates that we're looking at a
$90,000 $90,000 housing and housing
affordability all the things that we've
heard this morning and also as crystal
mentioned of the 351 communities in
Massachusetts each one of them has a
different way of zoning a different way
of permitting and what we're seeing is a
city of Boston and the housing the
Boston core doing a lot more production
than the rest of the state and that just
increases the pressures in the Greater
Boston area if you look at the city of
Boston's housing plan Mayor Walsh's plan
to build 53,000 units by 2025 they're
actually trending ahead of their
estimated targets so if you look at
permits and the number of housing units
in the pipeline those are all higher
than what was what they estimated they
were they estimated they would be but if
you look at the rest of the Greater
Boston area they're actually lagging so
what happens is the nonprofit's that are
working in the city of Boston and the
affordable housing developers who are
also in this room nonprofits and
otherwise our increasingly struggling
with the same issues of land scarcity
and housing prices so for to get to a
level that's affordable for a
middle-income household or an extremely
low income
sold you starting with the same cost for
land or for building and you have to add
on multiple subsidies to bring it down
to an affordability that works both for
median for median income households for
a low income and for moderate income
households and the challenge is really
in in resources its cobbling together a
range of public and private resources to
create affordability the nonprofits and
the for-profits and the area are
extremely innovative and extremely
creative
they usually the list of sources
includes a dozen or more sources from
the public from the federal government
and from local government and we are
actually in a state where the public
sector has taken this really seriously
just a couple of weeks ago the housing
bond bill was passed 1.8 billion dollars
of capital subsidy for affordable
housing development we have our own
state-funded housing subsidy which is
the Massachusetts rental voucher program
and all of these create affordable deep
affordability and affordability across
the spectrum of incomes but it's really
it's the same struggle so if you're if
you have a market that's only producing
housing at the upper end income levels
so typically any new production is not
aimed even at moderate income or middle
income households it's aimed at the
highest income and for it to filter down
will take decades it's when the housing
becomes substandard that it really
becomes affordable to lower-income
households so that kind of trickling
down will take decades so for us to be
able to meet the demand for
affordability we have to do we have to
act
I think the trickle is so if you look at
what's called naturally occurring
affordable housing it's typically the
much older stock in the poor
neighborhoods of the city so the
Dorchester Mattapan Roxbury where the
housing is substandard
and it's older stock and people are
often overcrowded and for us to make an
impact in new production so the focus on
transitory development for us to be able
to create housing that's affordable
across the spectrum for new households
coming into the city and to the region
we have to make sure that there is a
minimum level of affordability and that
we're maximizing affordable housing even
in new development I know that again the
the NIMBY effect is a natural one but I
also want to put out hope that there's a
Y MB movement yes in my backyard where
folks are getting together in places
like cambridge and somerville Jamaica
Plain Roslindale young people at the
local level to say that they want
density they want housing that spans the
income levels and they want
environmental stewardship that increases
density along transit and uses public
resources wisely terrific thank you so
it sounds like we really have a need to
go down two tracks perhaps once being
one being the the trickle down but which
may take longer but perhaps a good
long-term solution and another being
immediate need to do something to create
affordable housing in many of these
areas Jonathan are you working at Fannie
Mae on any types of products or
opportunities that might help in that
area yeah we're doing a lot right now
obviously very focused on this issue and
I'll just you know at a high level you
know there are there ways I think we can
address this issue it's just going to
require having a lot of people come
together and think about it and work
together sort of everyone turns their
key at once we can make progress which
is why events like this are really
important for us to bring smart people
to come together and recognize the issue
and talk about solutions but you know I
will say you know number one figuring
how we make better use of existing space
today is really critical and it just a
couple anecdotes we'll hear from nest
early later which has a great solution
of using existing empty net
housing they're companies like Co abode
that partner single moms so that they
can go into a home together again you've
got this the stock of housing that's not
being used and you could potentially
leverage it a little bit more you know
yesterday we had a reception and one of
the MIT spin-off startups is doing
robotics for furniture and his claim is
he can make a place feel twice the size
by having robotics rearrange the
furniture with the press of a button
right now talking Murphy beds we have to
put the pillows but really really
automated and so that's taking advantage
of space we have in the cities to make
it much more functional and easier to
use
we're Fannie Mae can play a big role in
our renovation programs and products by
offering finance to allow people to make
changes to existing housing to enable
some of these new ways of living that
can better optimize existing space I
also you know the other thing that we
have to think about is in a lot of parts
of this country we do have a lot of
houses and it's kind of strange you go
to Cleveland they say they're out of
housing stock you drive ten minutes east
of the city and there's just all these
big empty homes and so another thought
is how do we bring some of those
neighborhoods online now it's gonna take
some risk and somebody to go in and
finance those initial changes that's
another place where Fannie Mae I think
can play a big role hastening new
construction obviously these new
techniques in terms of building are
really critical but the industry is just
not ready to adopt it so you know you
say I'm gonna 3d print at home than one
that Tim mentioned he talked to the
permitting office and they said you know
the guy looked at him like a cow staring
at a closed gate right it was like they
have no idea how to handle this new
technology appraisers are in the same
place and so where Fannie Mae can sit we
can bring a lot of these people together
to help them understand the technology
and help advance what the appraisers are
doing you know another thing I'll say to
Bill's comment about filtering is
helping people move up and so Fannie Mae
is looking for ways to facilitate you
know if there's luxury housing move
people out of their starter homes into
the luxury homes an example of a company
we're partnering with just talking to
initially right now is a company called
NOC which if anybody's sold a home and
bought a home at the same time you know
that it's something akin to dental
surgery it's just really uncomfortable
and unpleasant you're worrying about a
bid here you got continuous it's just a
nightmare what they're trying to do is
allow they'll go out and buy the house
that you want to buy fix it up allow you
to move in and then they'll sell
the house that you're selling out of to
make that process easier and take
advantage of little realtor fees lower
renovation fees to improve that
transaction so if we can find a way to
help them get people out of starter
homes into new homes then that could be
a way of freeing up smaller housing
financing a construction is something
longer-term that Fannie Mae is really
looking into financing is a big part of
the cost that people look at when
they're building homes and we're
thinking about that and then the last
thing I'll mention you know this this
problem with you know the regulatory
environment building codes this is one
that we struggle with I think everybody
does which is you know Fannie Mae has a
scale player it's not like you can
change one rule and it has a massive
opportunity to change but I do think
that quantifying and recognizing what
some of the cost of building codes and
zoning are actually doing to cities
bringing that information to cities
providing them with resources to see
that is another way that I think Fannie
Mae can participate in being part of the
solutions thank you I see the clock
keeper is about to hit the buzzer and
I'm wondering do we have time for a
couple of questions from the audience
that work terrific if we have any feel
yes microphone is on your way thank you
hi my name is Sarah Kouta I work with
Pyatt associates and our architecture
firm down in Milton and just put it out
to the panel I'd like to just question
the the process here of filtering where
we all accept it as an acceptable method
for creating affordable housing when in
fact it's just disgusting it's talking
about deplorable living conditions and
places that nobody else wants to live
and that we think that's an acceptable
way to have more affordable housing come
online instead of questioning that in
the first place has an acceptable living
situation I don't think that's actually
how filtering works filtering mostly
works by carving up large spaces into
smaller spaces so you think about the
enormous number of single family units
that were carved up a hundred years ago
into duplexes and triplexes and it's not
necessarily a filtering in the quality
dimension
it's a filtering in the square feet
dimension and that's very effective
right now if you ask brokers the in the
suburbs the hardest units to sell are
twenty ten to twenty ten to thirty year
old McMansions just developers went
overboard and they built volume this is
during the 80s and 90s nobody wants
volume now they want quality and so
there are these houses out there with
large volumes and you sort of look at
them you go yeah yeah sure I could
probably get into that house and carve
it up into a three family but the last
time that was done hundred years ago we
didn't have zoning so you could change a
single family into a xxx without ever
going before a zoning board now you know
you're gonna get slammed if you try that
even though I think there are
potentially large number of 30-year old
houses that one might actually carve up
into duplexes or triple exes and that's
not a problem of quality with rats or
anything like that that's just a problem
of you know taking 4,000 or 5,000 square
feet in one unit and making two three or
four one thousand square foot units just
one other comment related to that too so
when we look at this effect so the
average tenure in a home used to bounce
between three maybe five years and it's
jumped up now the latest estimate I've
seen is ten years so people are staying
in their homes good homes
they've been maintaining them and this
year we'll probably see about four
hundred billion dollars spent on
renovations so what's happening is
they're staying in these reasonable
homes that might have been a one bedroom
home or a two-bedroom home and then
they're adding an addition to the back
or moving building it up and so those
are things that are just are taking
literally two and a half million starter
homes off the market so it's not the
lowest quality home so that your
questions are great when we have to be
cognizant of that there are a lot of
really nice starter homes that are
becoming big luxury homes I just wanted
to add really the it's sort of
multifamily housing that creates
affordability who has the potential for
affordability and if you look at what's
happening
again around around the state it's I
think they're just for communities that
permitted multifamily developments in
the last five years I think it was
Boston Cambridge and a couple of others
whereas 250 communities and
Massachusetts only permitted five units
or less so it's you know it's not
substandard housing it's when you look
at what's being built in the market and
the size and the quality for it to you
know for luxury finishes to become at
some point affordable to a middle-income
household it's gonna take time so it's
not coming down to substandard housing
really it's it's sort of over time that
luxury housing is being pared down to a
level where it's no longer attractive at
the highest end of the market but until
we build more multifamily housing I
think we're just gonna look at
unaffordability across the spectrum well
we could certainly continue this
discussion for quite some time but for
now we're out of time and I would just
like to take the opportunity to thank
the three panelists for their
willingness to share I'm Noelle Marcus
and I am the co-founder and CEO of nest
early and I'm here with my partner
Rachel Gore so nest early tackles some
of the issues that were all talking
about here today the issue of housing
affordability and Aging in Place with
one very simple solution we pair older
households who have extra space with
young people who are looking for a place
to stay for longer than one month so we
don't have too much time with you right
now so I just want to tell you a quick
story I want you to meet Brenda Brenda
lives in Roxbury in Boston and the she
lives in a beautiful beautiful townhouse
that's been in her family since 1946 but
it's been a few years since her kids
moved out and with her recent retirement
the strain and cost of caring for this
large home all by herself
is really starting to wear on her
so she's got an empty nest just a few
metro stops away we have Phoebus he's
about to start a graduate a five-month
graduate program actually at MIT
he's an architecture student he cares
about communities and he cares about
cities but he's a newcomer to the Boston
area and he's really looking for a more
meaningful and affordable experience
than the campus storm so we we would
call Phoebus a good egg with Nestor Li
Phoebus and Brenda connected and they
came to an arrangement where Phoebus was
able to secure an affordable room in
Brenda's home and in exchange he helped
out around the house and gardens a
couple hours a week but more than that
as you can see in this picture Brenda
and Phoebus really became friends
Brenda toward him around her
neighborhood showing him her favorite
architectural features of Roxbury and he
cooked her Greek meals so Brenda and
Phoebus their struggles are not unique
in the United States as everyone in this
room knows half of all renters are
paying an unsustainable portion of their
income on rent and at the same time our
aging population is skyrocketing by 2035
one out of three households in the US
will be headed by someone over the age
of 65 and the sad fact is that 50%
nearly half are going to be living alone
so when you ask folks kind of like
Brenda 90% say they want to stay in
their homes and their communities as
they age but they face similar
challenges like fixed and limited
incomes increasing home maintenance
costs and declining social networks so
Noel and I met just a few buildings away
over at MIT City Planning School we both
came here interested in innovative
approaches to solving this housing
affordability crisis as do many people
in this room
so when our school started a program
called design X which is a Business
Accelerator specifically focused on
innovations in the built environment we
knew that we had to apply like any good
nerds we went straight to the data when
we started brainstorming we pulled some
really quick numbers just matching
people one person to one bedroom so no
couple sharing a room
no kids sharing a room and we found that
every single night 54 million bedrooms
are sitting empty as we heard earlier
today this is not a resource that we can
leave untapped any longer necessarily
takes two widely proven models renting
rooms and on-demand tasking and
seamlessly combines them into an elegant
solution for these big problems were
facing we've been working thanks to the
help of design X during the school year
we laid the foundations of a fantastic
business and within just two weeks of
graduating we signed a formal
partnership with the city of Boston
around a pilot program with them last
fall it's been a smashing success and
we're now working to scale nationally
across the Greater Boston metro and
beyond so that we can ensure that more
people have access to this elegant
solution that increases housing
affordability we're effectively adding
new units to the housing stock at no
cost to municipalities or the greater
public we're also increasing
neighborhood stability enabling people
to stay in their homes even while
newcomers come to the neighborhood and
we're increasing social connectedness at
this time of deep social isolation and
division so how does it work
users can easily jump on our website at
necessarily IO create profiles hosts can
list their rooms and we verify everyone
with our multi-tiered screening process
that keeps the community safe and secure
guests can then reset reach out to hosts
they find appealing they can message
securely through our interface and then
move to phone Skype or meet in person to
find the right fit for them at that
point they can use our customizable
home-sharing agreement to agree to the
terms up front set expectations and make
sure that lines of communication are
open to ensure that this is a great
experience for everyone after that we
support with ongoing rent payments
customer service and make sure that
everyone has a great experience so what
we're trying to do we're really taking
an age-old concept of intergenerational
home sharing and bringing it into the
digital age and we are here to build a
movement and as Rachel said we're not
stopping with Boston we just announced
our expansion in the Boston region I was
actually at the mayor US mayor's
conference yesterday pitching 250
mayor's in downtown Boston and we really
believe that in partnership with cities
we can help ensure that housing
affordability and housing security is
not just for the privileged but for
everyone and if we can leave you with
one thought besides our story of Brenda
and Phoebus if you leave here today we
want you to to remember this phrase that
we cannot build ourselves out of this
housing crisis so thank you very much
hello my name is Tim Logan I'm a
reporter at the Boston Globe where I
write about housing and real estate and
we're gonna have Augusta panel here
today talking about essentially how we
build and how we build more affordable
housing more housing for the families of
the future I'm going to do a few
introductions here and we're gonna go
into a brief video and then and then
some Q&A see I guess I'll start with
introduction sorry Katie Swenson to the
left is vice-president resign and
sustainability at Enterprise Community
Partners one of the leading housing
nonprofits in the country her work
investigates how critical design
practice can instead promote economic
and social equity environmental
sustainability in healthy communities
to her right is Larry sass an associate
professor of architecture at MIT he
works a lot on fabrication and is
and I'm gonna be doing a brief video in
a few minutes
his bio includes the provocative wine
that he believes that handcrafted hand
operated construction will soon be a
thing of the past
which will be interesting for
construction workers Kyle quorum is the
CEO of L star ventures which is a large
Planned Unit development builder
they are building Union point the former
South Weymouth Naval Air Station in
suburban Massachusetts in suburban
Boston four thousand units it's about
the largest housing development underway
in Massachusetts today and they're
working a lot on smart cities technology
as they plan that huge project and I
here in my left is Bob Simpson vice
president of Fannie Mae affordable
mission business and so on the Urban
Land Institute CIFOR de belen workforce
housing Council there's a couple of
words to introduce before we get into
the video from Professor sass plus four
hundred thousand dollars give or take to
build a typical apartment here in
Greater Boston it's a lot of money that
drives up the cost of rents basically
from the start
cost thousands of dollars more a year to
keep that home and to cool it energy and
other built-in costs yeah didn't parking
requirements yet in zoning rules you
hadn't a lot of things that all adds up
to even if you can build the house which
cost a lot to build the house upfront
and then it costs a lot for that for
whoever lives in that house to maintain
it and and so that makes it very hard
even if you have land in this land
constrained expensive region to build
anything that anybody can afford so are
there things that we can do differently
are the different ways we can build or
the different ways we can design are the
different ways we can plan this housing
to bring those costs down and yeah make
make housing that people can afford
which is because I think what we're all
here to talk about today we have these
four people are at the forefront of that
conversation and but there's modular
housing or fabrication technological
advancement a lot of ideas and look
forward to getting into it we'll start
with with Professor sass has a brief
video that we can we can do about about
fabrication which is really on the
cutting edge of some of this stuff you
wanna go ahead sure I'm not running oh
yeah
oh it's directly from data we have all
observed how Amazon BMW and Apple have
use data to design manufacture and
control the delivery of their products
on a contrary modern construction is
driven by information with modern
construction people are expected to
interpret and calculate information
manufactured thousands of components and
assemble those components with handheld
tools let's face it we continue to work
with very old non-measurable systems of
production 3d printing is just the
beginning the way it works is it starts
with a 3d model that is then measured
data is generated for machining that
data drives manufacturing and assembly
of layers the results of which are a
beautiful solid object this way of
working really does is a glimpse into
the future of new possibilities and how
it can relate to the building industry
our group works differently we work with
large interlocking planar parts all cut
from laser cutters and CNC machines I
had a chance to build a full-scale
example back in 2008 and since then we
realized that the possibilities are
endless
the system works the same as 3d printing
we start with a model break that into
smaller parts planes and contours
subdivide that into smaller shapes and
develop that into 2d ready for laser
cutting or CNC manufacturing it's a
great and flexible system it allows us
to make again just about anything what's
next I actually think it's pretty simple
we need to put our heads together and
build a digital platform that'll prepare
us for all the new and exciting
technology
to come
[Music]
so that's a pretty exciting vision how
far down the road is that do you think
because we don't see that right now I
don't think you'll see it from quite
some time I don't know I it's kind of
hard to say give it a timing yeah now
when you think about the two big things
I think you could think about it at MIT
that have come from MIT that have taken
that took a while the first was a CAD
was invented here in 1962 and that
really didn't become a business
enterprise until 10-15 years later and
3d printing was invented here not a
plastic one but a powder one and that
one also took about 20 years so it takes
a while for something to go from
discovery to actual production it's it's
a very long process it seems like this
this conversation around how we build
does take a long time modular
multi-family housing for instance has
been in existence for a long time 15 or
20 years we are only now here in Boston
beginning to see the first handful of
large multifamily buildings getting
built with essentially podiums and
modular units on top of that I was
talking somebody from talking
construction this morning they're doing
a project right now in Charlestown but
there are I can count on one hand in the
city of Boston why why does it take so
long for this for this field if you
think that's a good thing I guess first
off why does it take so long for these
advancements in building technology to
make it into the market yeah I think I
think you know one of the challenges
with modular is that it's different
right and so I think from our
perspective as a as a financing source
of multifamily housing the first thing
you want to know is how does what does
the valuation look like right so how
does it appraised and making sure that
when the appraiser comes in and looks at
a multi-family building that's been
built in them with a modular approach
that they're trained educated they
understand you know how that component
has been built
understand how you know it's going to
stand up over time and making sure that
when there is an appraisal it can be
comparable with something that's been
stick built and that takes education it
takes training it takes time and so the
market has to get comfortable with it we
have to get comfortable with resales we
have to get comfortable with the
operating performance of the property
and that over time then I think that
becomes much more broadly accepted you
know we've financed a number of modular
buildings in the multifamily space we
think they perform extremely well I
think every years you're gonna see more
of them and as and as you continue to
build that market and you see that
there's not really a distinction between
on the performance side between modular
and stick built I think you'll see more
acceptance that's in the lending and
investment community how about on the on
the policy and permitting side anybody
work with municipalities zoning rules
and things like that yeah we do all the
time and so you've got both the building
code which might be a state level code
and then you have inspections which are
done at the local level right and so you
need adoption there of I'd say
receptivity to some of these new ideas
right and so that takes time to make its
way through the process as well how
about community acceptance of this sort
of thing and the design around it and
making these sort of different styles of
building more amenable to the neighbors
and frankly to residents yeah I think
here in Massachusetts we have actually
one of the most difficult policy
environments and you know I recently saw
sort of an analysis of cost of
construction in terms of time and
difficulty of approvals process and
Massachusetts regs or Boston ranked
really amongst the worst and so it's
really interesting you know what are the
kind of conditions that we want to put
in place to both sort of assure quality
but also understand a little bit who are
we building for and how we did an
analysis enterprise did an analysis with
the Joint Center for Housing last year
on asking the question does the
Massachusetts qualified allocation plan
the
qap is the policy document which governs
decisions that are made around which
projects will will receive investment
from the state subsidy methodology and
and our question was does the QAP
incentivize design excellence or not and
you know spoiler alert like not so much
right there are some measures in there
for sustainability features mostly the
unseen sort of elements which are
important absolutely essential no one
disagrees with that they could do more
in fact but what's interesting is that
the decisions about what fits in what
gets built is in large part sort of left
to a kind of community process and how
then that community process is run or
not run and point a huge sort of onus on
the project so there's a real privilege
of the people who are there already
which many would say fantastic right you
always want to make sure that you know
buildings are kind of fitting into their
neighborhood fabric and adding to the
both the beauty and the sort of
walkability and all the different
features of a neighborhood but if we're
actually trying to say that we want to
diversify neighborhoods we want to do
urban infill we know density is
important we understand that technology
and new systems of building are going to
be the ways that we're gonna get to
affordability then we can't always rely
on this sort of sense of let's just keep
doing it the way we've always done it
let's go with the familiar let's let the
sort of more parochial vision be the
vision that makes the decisions I think
- you know what's gonna drive that is
how we use data right and how we capture
data and use it to educate local
communities how we use it to drive the
design process
I mean if we can quantify that it costs
X amount less to build using modular
technology and that that value then is
going to get transferred down to the
community and to the renter's who live
in the property and and the investors
right then that's something that you can
use to educate the local governing board
you can use data around your prospective
renters you know I anyone who's ever
been in any everybody here has been to
an affordable or a conventional
multi-family property right and the
first thing you see when you walk in the
door is a gym and it's never used right
we don't really maximize the space we
have no one ever stopped to ask when
they were building this property who's
gonna use the gym right we're starting
to ask that question now we're working
with partners who are actually working
with builders to go out and survey the
prospective renter base to say what do
you need how much do you make what do
you want and what they're finding the
case of gyms is nobody wants a gym they
want a bike rack right well bike racks
are a lot cheaper and you can use that
space in a gym to put another unit in
that can collect more income right you
can do other things within so as we look
about how we design properties it's not
just about how we build it in the
construction phase it's about how we put
the building together so that we're
maximizing space how are we doing our
unit mix to make sure it's matching the
needs of the neighborhood and all of
that comes down to data and if you can
quantify the value and you can
communicate that I think you can get
more broader local acceptance how do you
do that over time right your planning
and permitting a building right now
that's gonna open in two and a half
years and then but ten but that building
hopefully lasts for decades
how do you how do you make a building
that's flexible enough to evolve over
time or a project maybe I think one of
the other issues is that the buildings
were building now are going to be around
as the effects
climate change are starting to hit in
the next 20 30 50 years and so this kind
of mandate over making sure that we're
actually sort of future proofing
buildings is a critical piece that
hasn't necessarily come up today this
idea that the buildings of yesterday we
know that stick construction stick built
framing balloon framing was invented in
1820 and most of our buildings are
typically using that kind of methodology
but the world that we're living in is
shifting and has shifted so dramatically
so in fact these projects that you know
some of the projects that we're building
today first of all they were designed 5
7 10 years ago they work that way so
slowly through the kind of process but
meanwhile we need to be designing
buildings that are going to adapt to
climate change be able to withstand you
know flooding and other issues and we're
learning about that technology and I
think we sort of know in our minds I'm
sure Larry and his colleagues can tell
us sort of exactly what we should be
doing but this kind of will over
deciding that we're gonna really solve
this problem I think is really to me
what's lacking yeah if I could jump in
there so the reason I'm sitting here as
a developer of this property called
Union point isn't because I'm trying to
promote real estate development cuz it's
not about that it started it's exactly
what you're talking about Katie so this
situation here in Massachusetts with the
scarcity of land sort of over specified
regulatory environment that can drag out
a permitting process for years it's very
expensive very risky makes it very hard
to do innovative things
there was a response at the state level
in the local level to do something
different with this property that's only
12 miles from the city center of Boston
and and so the intent was to not do
things the same way
so it's it's not really Boston but it's
Boston like in its qualities it's very
urban it's not suburbs either but it's
in the suburb so it's this exurban
environment but what it's really
supposed to be is this living laboratory
where we explored these things and so
when they asked our company to come
attempt this sort of impossible task you
know we told them that there were a
couple things that we're going to have
to happen if this had any chance of
success and one was that the over
specified design kind of standard goes
away that the best practice is whatever
we determined and it just happens and
that we remove years of regulatory
hand-wringing and then 28 days are
approved so that market risk question
that professor Wheaton was talking about
is eliminated and it allows us to think
in terms of best practices today and
implement them in a few months and it's
that's a that's a game changer when you
can start thinking that way and then go
beyond just don't keep building the same
kind of housing faster but how can we do
it differently how can technology
improve the lives of people living in
that housing how can we be more
inclusive with that housing and use that
speed so there are some developers in
the room that are building at our
property and we go to them and say
listen we'll welcome you here but we
want you to make housing for seniors
mixed into your market rate housing we
want you to make housing for people with
disabilities mixed in so they're
assimilated and not segregated and so
this whole the reason we're here is
because the entire place is a big
experiment to answer these questions and
ask them and get some of them right and
get some of them wrong but be open
source about the potential in the hope
that maybe more places will allow this
kind of development how does that
translate into lower costs whether it's
lower cost of construction or lower cost
of occupancy over time but in our case
you remove years of legal and
engineering and and and upfront cost
that a lot of companies incur right and
you remove market risk as well people
can hit the bull's eye with almost a
hundred cent certainty knowing that
economic conditions they're going to
come out in our builders can break
ground in under five months from pns to
construction during approval which is
extraordinary in Boston that would be
three to five years so you eliminate
market
we're also able to unilaterally decide
that will lower prices for certain kinds
of housing to give the developers
incentives to create more affordable
housing more workforce housing more
inclusive housing and reward them with
lower land prices in Boston in
particular there is over the years been
been a lot of debate around Union
construction and the additional cost
that that adds one of the arguments I
hear when people say we should lower the
cost of we should do various things
whether it's permitting or or more
flexibility on Union rules then people
say well the profits are just gonna go
to the developer that's not really gonna
translate and they're still gonna rent
for the most that they can get and
they'll pocket the difference how do you
how do you counter that argument when we
said we shouldn't we should do these
advanced technologies to lower the cost
of construction but the market is still
very high how do we see how do I the
renter see any benefit from this go
ahead let me just add the jumping cuz it
to to to conversations all right there's
one conversation about policy and people
and how all of those things happen and
then there's technology right so
cellphones there's the technology behind
the cell phone making sure to it that a
signal gets from one place to the other
and then there is who's going to price
the cell phone who's going to deal with
the regulations behind it when it comes
to construction and technology around
construction is an incredibly neglected
field you have students who graduate
from architecture schools or students
who graduate from high schools they
understand how computer design works
they understand how laser cutters work
they understand out CNC machines work
construction workers are still in this
at the state where that's not part of
the training it's not a mandate so you
you have a bunch of people I'm talking
about really more for single-family
wooden houses you have a bunch of people
who show up with basic tools for spend
two days setting up to build a small
house I don't mean to dominate this but
I love riding my bike around
Massachusetts and whenever I see a gun
or a construction site I always ask
myself I wonder how long it's going to
take that crew to get set up with all of
their tools before they start hammering
anything and usually that's two or three
days that the homeowner is paying with
technology you should be able to walk in
parts and put the parts together as solo
parts and I have to say also with
prefabricated construction it's still
the same stick build in doors they're
still not using new technology it's
still the same crew but you're heating
the environment that they're working in
you're providing nice bathrooms
administrators a whole bunch of other
things that you don't pay for with stick
build-out outdoors so what I'm saying is
if you're gonna really talk about
technology it's it's a it's a different
kind of conversation than talking about
regulations I think you know just from
the financing end of it if you can cut
down your construction your time of
construction right that's a shorter term
construction loan yep right so you're
gonna save say you saved six months on
your construction loan that's great
let's say if it's on an affordable deal
you of a four word commitment for the
permanent loan right well if you're
forward committing for a shorter amount
of time that's gonna cost list as well
right so so it does impact the cost and
I think you know as it relates to
affordability and you know what's yeah I
always look at this way right you know
technology doesn't have a conscience
right it's not supposed to but we do
right we also understand the
sustainability of any development
long-term is based on the ability of
people to actually pay the rent and you
can't have a sustainable development
where the majority of people are paying
more than 50% of the rent of their
income for rent for a long period of
time so I think developers I think
policymakers I think people who finance
affordable housing realize that you
actually have to there is a long term
sustainability argument for making sure
that we are that we're addressing the
affordability issue in order for
everyone to be in this business for a
long period of time and either we do it
now and work with local governments to
find ways in which we can make the
compliance and monitoring and fee based
portion of this more affordable and
simplified or it's going to be done and
it may not be done in a manner that's
that's all that efficient yeah I mean
we're we're actually partnering with the
unions again advancing this idea of
being sort of a big beta for all kinds
of different
and so the Carpenters Union for example
has been very innovative very
progressive in terms of looking at new
ways to build now there may not be where
professor sass is yet and we hope that
they get there someday soon but but like
with jobsite steel for example a
prefabricated light gauge steel as
opposed to wood which might have you
know been cut in a factory environment
for you better quality control and
drives from cost down and then modular
units we're looking at that with them as
well and so these are areas you wouldn't
normally think of a Carpenters Union you
know moving but if it leads to better
quality lower pricing and it can protect
jobs for them at the same time we found
that to be willing partners jump in just
listening to so much of the conversation
earlier today and I was trying to sort
of toggle I think back and forth between
some of these large data systems and
then my sort of experiences on the
ground in communities and I've been I've
been traveling quite a bit lately so
I've been in communities like San Ysidro
California on the border of Tijuana
where we're building a 750 million
dollar border control station it's gonna
be LEED certified
traffic's backed up to San Diego right
affordable housing crisis no community
benefits agreement right so where's the
will and when we're talking about
cutting costs it's really about our
priorities it's not necessarily about
the money the money is out there and
some form or another so what's our
priority in that situation I was last
week in the Mississippi Delta could be
another country practically to Boston it
was their scene to neighborhoods we have
a program called the Enterprise Rose
architectural fellowship and we
partnered a fellow with an Economic
Development Corporation in Greenwood
Leflore County in in Greenwood
Mississippi and one of the
first neighbourhoods that she worked in
actually was the neighborhood MIT had
done some planning work in four years
neighborhood called Baptist town it's
very typical southern situation on the
other side of the tracks the grounds
lower it's a little soggy very poor
neighborhood and after Katrina some of
you are familiar with the Katrina
cottage right so architects newer Venis
architects went down and designed these
modular cottages which sat at the
airport in Greenwood for I think seven
years because to get them on site
involved this kind of ridiculously
complex legal and sort of structure to
have you know the governor of
Mississippi changed the this and the
city and all these things
so anyway I'm there last week and all
those cottages are now in place and I
got to visit with a homeowner who has
lived in that neighborhood her whole
life her name is Dorothy she's in her
70s and her mortgage payment is I think
under $200 a month so perfect so I start
with her and our Rose fellow Emily and
actually had this discussion about
writing a will right so she's now at
this place in her life where she's
making her mortgage payment she always
pays early cuz who knows what might
happen she says and she's at the point
where she's ready to look into like well
what is her life insurance policies they
just you know does she have one she's
not exactly sure and then how does she
write a will so that the property will
transfer I guess what's my point in
bringing these things up I think that I
think that there's absolutely
technologies that are available there's
no question about it the katrina cottage
in a way was an innovation at the time
was saying FEMA trailers are a disaster
we know it how do we do a better version
of that but when that technology
solution
then sits at the airport for seven years
because of this kind of political and
regulatory environment how do we break
through that so in our case it's you
know Emily rush Elliott down there
duking it out every day with the city
the county the state trying to put these
pieces together and be one of those kind
of connectors and what you see is that
in the process of that she and her
husband who now have a firm called Delta
design-build actually started an
economic development organization that
was basically hiring local people to do
the site work the the local you know to
do they have a gardening and landscaping
business now they had a they were
building the on-site pieces so I think
we should be able to sort of figure this
stuff out you know and I think that
while we're looking at these kind of
macro trends which I heard the data and
and I've been the person on the panel
sometimes who's talking about those
macro trends but I think we also have to
recognize that you know these kinds of
solutions that Kyle's talking about like
we can figure this out we have all the
pieces but if we're building 750 million
dollar leed-certified border control
stations you know where are our
priorities and how are we sort of
understanding that this is not an
academic discussion this is you know a
critical relevant timely situation that
we have to kind of dig in and make sure
that we're solving the one thing that
strikes me in writing about housing is
is this is one of the biggest challenges
facing our country right at a national
level whether it's in affluent high-cost
cities like Boston or low-income
communities like the Gulf Coast of
Louisiana I just work in st. Louis huge
affordable housing crisis in st. Louis
which has really very inexpensive
housing but there's no affordable
housing it gets built there and and
there the solutions are being done at a
local level in different towns in
different cities you have different
people like mayor Walsh and Boston who
are sincerely trying to tackle this but
it's always like you said
sort of an individual community level
basis how do you scale or what you're
doing in South Weymouth right that's an
individual project it's great but it's
it's only so big yeah so we feel it
nationally yes so we're we're not trying
to be the answer for everything or even
suggest that anything we're doing
applies anywhere else but when you kind
of care about asking the right questions
and the outcomes sometimes you make
these little discoveries so an apartment
developer mark you're a department
developer does not have to create
affordable housing in our project they
can just do market rate housing but we
ask them to do some work for us housing
and that's great and and they're usually
pretty happy to do this most if we price
it appropriately for them but there's a
missed opportunity they have under the
federal building code they have to build
some units that are handicap accessible
but there's this concept called visit
ability there's a an advocate here in
Boston named John Kelly
he's a wheelchair access advocate and he
says you know imagine a world in which
you can go from your house to someone
else's house you can go visit everyone
and there isn't a curb there isn't a
door stop that prevents you you know a
brownstone that your friend lives in the
second floor you can actually go up and
see him right so you know he's
challenged us to think of how to build a
city where everyone can go visit
everyone else and so when you talk to
the developers of the market rate
housing or the workforce housing
whatever
nobody's creating a shared living unit
and it's so desperately needed we've got
people living in group homes that want
to be independent they want to be part
of society and it's just this little
disconnect between the folks that do the
same thing every time and they're
actually very willing to to make slight
adjustments to open up this opportunity
because there are four point nine
million people with disabilities who get
their you know housing subsidy through
SSI who don't can't afford housing right
and so this problem could be solved by
just connecting those two worlds you
know it's not a subsidy program just
designing the building a little bit
differently so that you could have a
caregiver and two people with
disabilities in a unit and it's and so
we're finding open receptivity to it in
the hope that they'll do this in more
places once they learn how easy it is
how beneficial it is to our community so
I don't know if anyone will do it again
after they leave here but the hope is
that maybe
some will you know I think one of the
biggest challenges to bring anything to
scale is and we've found this at Fannie
Mae because this is what you know what
you do right our job is to go out and
attract capital from all over the world
and put it to work for affordable
housing whether it's single-family or
multifamily right but in order to do
that you need scale and you need
standardization and those are two things
that you don't often think about when
you're innovating right you know I
always say that you know if it's cool
and it's interesting and everybody wants
to talk about it that's innovation and
if it's boring and repetitive and puts
everybody to sleep that's success
and that's the challenge right because
you have to take innovation and make it
boring when we started our green
financing program seven years ago nobody
had ever built a product that gave an
incentive for borrowers to save energy
or water or provide an additional
proceeds for them to do that right
we were yelled at we had borrowers call
us up and tell us we were crazy we
probably were we kept doing it over the
first four years I think we had four
failed products we closed two loans
right we kept at it right this was
innovative we were doing innovative
things but it wasn't to scale today
we're the largest global issuer of green
bonds in the world we've done over 30
billion dollars worth of business and
what we've learned is that you have to
take things take that innovation and
find ways to simplify it right we
collect we don't collect infinite
amounts of data we don't we collect ten
right you have to save energy here save
water here we took this radical idea
that you can save 20% water on every
multifamily property in the country you
know how you do it it's not really
innovative it's replacing your toilets
right that saves water so let's go do it
and let's do it as many times as we
possibly can and so you have to make it
repetitive you have to make it boring
and you have to also enforce some
standardization and be willing to make
that
trade-off you have to make sure that
you're training people along the way and
you're treating cost reduction as in
part of an ecosystem so the biggest
challenge we had was making sure the
folks that were doing the green energy
audits that they were all on the same
page with each other and that they all
understood what we wanted and that they
can all look at multifamily properties
in the exact same way everywhere across
the country and if you want to get
modular off the ground you have to make
sure that appraisers are doing the same
thing ok but then again if you if you um
what's about boring and repetitive right
like Kyle do you know how much time it
takes for you probably are going to
install thousands of toilets in those
units not me but you it could be depends
upon how bad things - yeah you know how
long it takes to install each toilet you
won't know how long it takes for them to
take it out of the package screw it down
put in that little wax ring and walk
away that's data that you don't have
right so when you move on to the next
property you have no idea that this
company is gonna use a better faster
cheaper method right and if you think
about how cars are made and you look at
design for manufacturing they know those
numbers know how long it takes to put a
small customer a clip onto each part and
they can optimize how that works there's
a lot of data that's missing yes we
there's a lot of stuff we don't know and
right now I'm certain whatever price
they gave you to build you could
probably double it alright cuz that's
the way it works here at MIT right
whenever we build something here it's
always whatever the estimate is it's
always double after it's done right and
the time is always doubled so there are
a lot of data points we're missing you
know it's in Toronto and in the
homebuilding world they say that the
national home builders who actually
comprise a minority of all the homes
that get built are closer to knowing
they know how many board feet how many
nails that kind of thing they say that
the local builders the small guys don't
know if they even made a profit until
they close the house right and they have
no clue because they're not standardized
in any way so the whole industry could
benefit from improvements in these areas
there's no question that it should be
viewed more as a manufacturing
operational kind of thing as opposed to
this artist artisinal kind of interval
so are you are you profiting because
you're charging more to install that
toilet than a local contractor right
right all right I know that's the way it
works here right a wall costs a lot more
to install at MIT but we just jack up
the prices because there are other
things going on so how do we get that
data and uh you know it's one thing when
you said with a large tract builder
that's building a giant subdivision they
can standardize to a degree but how do
you get that data well you have to see
it as being important I have to see it
as being part of the cost and you also
have to see it as a developer is I want
to increase my profit it's really a
money thing right and you know I I don't
know and you also have to develop
technologies from measuring right now we
we don't measure self we don't know how
long it takes somebody to deliver parts
and move picking up little tools you can
imagine if somebody made a car the way
that we make a small house with from
Home Depot yeah would car cost a lot
more oh yeah
well we're so there's one area where
this applies absolutely and that is
every single building in our community
under normal rules would have their own
heating and cooling and they may or may
not have solar geothermal or wind you
know sustainably generated energy but
you know if we're striving for
you know carbon neutrality in the city
how do you do it if you don't control
all those systems you think about the
inefficiency and then the duplication of
all those for redundancy and everything
and a huge waste waste of time and money
and so what we're trying to convince
people to do is trust us and let us
build a centralized system where
innovation can be spread universally and
but we don't have great data on what the
savings are we know it'll be cheaper we
just don't know quite how much yet
because it isn't done on wide enough
scale yet to be able to measure right
but to our astonishment virtually
everyone is agreed to do it but they're
going into it knowing that it's kind of
an unknown you know and so there's a
spirit of innovation there but they have
to be encouraged and and have be
reassured and backstopped but we're
finding receptivity to that and we're
hoping that the data is really
supportive of more of these centralized
systems you know but we don't know I
think as we think about it
we want to be able to attract more
investors you affordable housing and one
of the untapped opportunities that we
see is the willingness of social impact
investors all over the world to put
money into commercial real estate in the
United States and what we're finding is
they're asking you know so we're out we
have a team out in Europe today selling
green bonds the question that social
impact investors ask is is it reducing
cost is it increasing affordability does
it improve local communities and
neighborhoods and does it reduce your
environmental footprint right of those
four data points we can prove one eye we
can prove that it's reducing the
environmental footprint we know that
with our green financing program that on
average a property saves $50,000 a year
and annual operating expenses when they
go green right they tenant saves about
one hundred and thirty dollars a year in
utility costs right we know that a lot
of those are projections next year we'll
actually have the actual data right
we're gonna put that through to our
investors so that they can see that we
don't really know what the we can't
quantify the value of affordability
which is something that I think we need
to be thinking about in terms of
innovation you know how do we quantify
the benefit of someone paying 30% of
their income for rent versus 50% of
their income for rent I can tell you
that extra 20% you're not spending on
your rent you're more than likely going
to spend in your local neighborhood
right so there's an impact to your local
tax base if we can quantify that data
you know we can help make sure that
local communities understand that when
they do a property tax abatement for an
affordable property there's actually a
payback and maybe it's a net positive we
don't know but maybe it is we know if we
can reduce costs how much of that
translates back to the investor which in
turn in cents more investment how much
of that accrues back to the renter when
you design a property how does it extend
the useful life how does it improve the
health and well-being of the person that
lives there all of these are data points
that we can actually quantify but in
order for us to take that back and show
it to our investors we want four or five
days
points for each one we don't want a
million we don't want one for every
community because every community is
different every community isn't
different right we want five or six data
points we can go back and say this is
what it does yeah it's not going to be
perfect but it's going to tell the right
story or that or the most accurate story
I actually met with your sustainable
communities team last week on Thursday
in DC and and like many groups both
enterprising Fannie Mae are really
trying to look at housing as one piece
of a larger ecosystem of course like we
all know when you choose where you want
to live you're choosing like where your
kids are gonna go to school how are you
gonna get to work where are you gonna
shop like these things are not unique to
be right these are universal premises
and so we have developed a framework
that's called opportunity 360 you can go
online you can enter sort of a zip code
and you can understand how how a
neighborhood is essentially sort of
stacking up in terms of these sort of
elements how is it transit friendly is
it food and health friendly is it sort
of providing the educational or access
to jobs and opportunities so I think
we're starting to develop some of these
systems I think this question though
around larger industry adoption and
cooperation is actually one of the
things that is so critical right now and
you know even the term affordable
housing is tricky right we've learned
that like we actually know that we did a
study with a group called frameworks
that was sort of analyzing sort of
public response and opinion to words
including the term affordable housing
which we all use and those of us who are
sort of Hauser's are really invested in
the idea of affordable housing for me
it's all good it's only good but I think
that housing and real estate crosses
this kind of line but
sort of self-determination and public
policy so like well I bought my house
and I'm paying my mortgage and I'm going
to sell my house for X it's like it's a
consumer mentality around sort of you
know transaction and investment that we
feel very personally and there's a sense
that housing is like that other thing
that project that apartment building
it's not necessarily equated with my
home and where I live so I think it's an
industry number one we actually need to
get smarter around understanding how to
align our efforts around language around
a kind of perception around really being
clear about what we're what we're
talking about which is I think at the
core it's basically sort of providing
you know ensuring that everyone in our
communities has you know a high-quality
safe and stable home where they can
raise their kids and get on with their
lives
right it's not sort of it's not it's not
a product it's not you know it's sort of
a very basic goal but I think the
industry could do a lot of work around
aligning around some of these word
choices going on a bit more of maybe a
marketing campaign you know housing
wasn't a policy issue in the last
presidential election didn't even appear
you hear it it I know the mayor's are
talking about it you know obviously the
mayor's are closer to the ground
the mayor's conference they're talking
about it but it's not a national issue
it's not perceived as a national policy
issue and I think it's incumbent on sort
of the the diverse and aligned
professionals who care about housing
everybody including the most vulnerable
people in our communities to really
align and kind of coalesce for you know
seek and provide the data points and
sort of move move the discussion into a
next round well it sounds like a great
place to throw it open to QA we've got
five or ten minutes for questions from
the audience
I have two questions one is for mr. Kyle
cork um you know in I don't agree with
you by the way Katie about affordable
affordability shoes affordability is a
problem and if it's not being brought up
nationally it's because the poor don't
have a voice but let me ask you mr.
Kirkham in terms of your construction
practices
why can't you allow greater sweat equity
participation you know like the IQ model
you have the package you bring it in you
install some things yourself that's the
first question second question is from
mr. Larry says I feel that we I'm an
architect that we as architects are
useless in terms of innovation because
we don't understand engineering in order
to becoming innovative we have to be
equally ingenious also so two questions
was mine a question or a statement
sounds like yes so sweat equity is
interesting we don't actually build the
unit's where the land developer but
we're trying to foster innovation and
where we're actually trying to create
affordably priced housing using playing
that game the nuance game of language
that looks exactly like market rate
housing and then mix it in as well so
it's tricky we can push the builders
only so far sometimes the lenders have
requirements that things be done so this
is all brand-new everything's being
built from scratch we're trying to break
some of the models but in some cases for
it to be most effective we have to work
with the system and look for you know
subtle innovations in that system I love
the sweat equity model though I think
it's a great idea Katie I I would just
ask you to expand your idea regarding
affordability and you were referencing
families raising young children one of
the failures I think in the discussion
about affordability it's people who own
a home and want to downsize
need to find an affordable place to go
so that they can stay in their community
continue to have roots in the community
and that is a very significant issue in
the Boston metropolitan area now I loved
the nest early idea earlier today I have
a 22 year old who's not my own living
with me this year it's super affordable
for her and it's awesome for us because
she provides just another perspective
and joy in our household which is really
nice so I think some of these ideas
about actually leveraging our the space
we have more effectively are really
important you know here in Boston we're
so lucky to have Amy Schechtman and
Jewish community housing for the elderly
as one of like the leading thinkers on
which what Amy is very clear on calling
Aging in community as opposed to Aging
in Place and this idea that we do need
to sort of be providing kind of more
communal dense smaller environment to
support seniors as they age and make
sure that we're building in the kind of
social design and physical design
features that are going to keep people
healthier over the long term she's
determined with many many others to kind
of crack this nut about investing in in
high quality housing as opposed to
investing in healthcare so she's sort of
making the bet that we could keep people
out of assisted living almost entirely
which again when you look at sort of the
value streams about where we're spending
our investment how do we invest
proactively into the kind of solutions
that are providing like these quality of
life and health outcomes as opposed to
investing in sort of a patient-centered
health care model go ahead as you say
that that's that sounds like we've
covered the whole lifespan from building
the housing to
the end and it's about the end we could
go on for probably another hour here
throw one up quick because I was
thinking about the gentleman who talked
about architects participating in the
process and the one thing that you learn
about and Design School is discovery you
learn how to discover new ideas you
learn how to just connect things
together and if you think about
affordability if you think about your
phone your phone has replaced a host of
things that we accept player television
set there are a bunch of things that are
replaced by the phone right if you think
about it in terms of innovation around
the home there are a lot of things that
we're just now thinking about turning
doors and windows and to heaters we get
rid of the furnace using wireless
electricity which is an up-and-coming
technology get rid of all of the outlets
that are buried in our walls and buried
in our ceilings wiring right if you
think about those costs going away
shimming doors and windows shimming
thousands of doors and windows all of
that stuff all of those costs add up and
if you really want to think about
affordability you really just have to
think about how technology can replace
things the way that the phone has it's
more than just looking at is but it's
the mindset it's the way you think about
how you want to transform a home well
it's a lot to think about
for us for our panel is great
conversation thank you guys it's a
pleasure to be here this morning it's a
pleasure to be closing and to have
learned a lot about affordability and
about housing and I will talk about that
and also introduce my view on how
prefabrication and offsite technology is
something that was introduced in the
last panel can also help to actually
help to make affordability and housing
meet and I will also talk about
architecture with capital a and not just
about construction but basically my my
team is under studio and myself we've
been for many years designing building
testing with a wide range
of construction technologies and
delivery methods certainly introducing
prefabrication as a way to as was
addressed earlier on improve quality
improve the control of time and under
control of risk in the sides of
construction and the control of cost in
the construction and we have tested
these with precast concrete with steel
and also discovered some of the
limitations of prefabrication that have
to do with moving heavy parts around so
in MIT we continued a research that has
to do with lightness and with
introducing new materials and testing
structures that reduce the weight of the
of the structures that we built and we
developed as you can see in the top some
are some structures that work with
compression and just use foam which is
98% air to to test some very small
housing unit and then in the lower part
mixing foams with other materials like
steel to enhance the performance like we
learnt in in with pre-stress concrete so
having tested having acquired certain
experience building and working with
different technologies we decided to
give a try and and develop a solution
that for the housing market in the u.s.
that would bring into the equation many
of the things that we had learnt about
materials and how those materials can
can come together in an easy way that
will lower the cost of construction and
therefore be able to to build more
affordably and we became around guinea
pigs
we decided to build our own homes we are
researchers but we are architects and
builders we are very proactive and
because we need solutions urgently we
think it is worth actually prototyping
and and getting the the ideas built as
quick as possible so we took this
experiment we bought these one-story
garage in Brookline and we decided to
build or expand our home on top of it
and it had to be very light because we
didn't want to spend extra money in
reinforcing their foundations so we
designed a kit of parts these parts had
to be as big as possible to minimize the
time of construction on the side
minimize also the the the hassle in the
neighborhood and and also minimize the
cost of the assembly because as you know
labor in the u.s. it's super expensive
so one of the things that we like about
prefabrication we are aware that there's
a lot of prejudice and a lot of
misunderstanding of what prefabrication
can imply in the construction sector but
the fact is that for us it allows us to
bring construction logics into the
design logic and this means eliminating
uncertainties and being able to fix
these issues very early on in the
process so we designed the house we
designed all the assembly process and
when it got the time off looking at how
we were going to pay for this we
discovered that it was actually very
unaffordable to build it in the US and
so we decided to to believe in Spain
where we had our team of architects and
engineers and and we set up a factory
small factory space where we continued
to develop the technology as we were
building the parts of the house when you
look at how a prefabrication how things
come to the site you have to bear in
mind of course the travel and how these
parts are going to fit in the tracks or
containers that actually need to deliver
them on the site the technology that we
developed is actually it's nothing out
of this world it's using of the shelf
materials widely available pretty cheap
but assembled in all the intelligence is
placed in how these materials come
together how they resolve the structure
how they resolve the enclosure and the
thermal performance and how the
mechanicals are placed so all the basics
actually all the fundamental aspects of
the house are integrated in this
technology that when it comes to the
site because it has been highly
pre-engineered everything feeds pretty
smoothly and again this was an
experiment
this was our prototype it could have not
worked so smoothly but in fact it did so
as much as we thought also about the
technology we were thinking about the
architecture and how you know what
contemporary architecture means today
and means in our cities and how can we
build affordably without it looking
cheap or without it looking old and we
were also thinking about space and about
flexibility and some of the things that
were discussed previously how what are
the family structures today how people
leave what kind of spaces they need so I
mean this is our home that is
essentially thought for us we just
needed a big space but it is a home that
has made us think a lot on how you know
we sometimes when when we do development
which sometimes place the attention in
aspects that are not really adding value
to what is built so our effort is really
to add value
- those things that are meaningful to
those aspects of the home that will
create the resilience and that will
allow the home to change over time as
needed so as I said this house is a
laboratory it was an experiment that was
meant to help us open up discussions
with other stakeholders to be able to
say hey we've proven our concept and and
we're not just talking about you know a
nice idea of our researcher at MIT but
this really can be built and so we moved
forward to create Warhol world homes
connecting with courageous developer and
architect in in Boston our partners the
the Curtis family and we started
thinking about when wide range of a
housing options that are needed from
small units hotel units spaces for
residences for students to live work
spaces studio spaces loft spaces and to
high-rises structures and how a you know
off-site constructions are not just
meant for single-family homes but as
cities really need to become denser
habitats how can construction
methodologies help in that endeavor so
all of these types that we are that we
are envisioning use again the same
technology that we are developing that
is very light and easy to build as as it
is built in a factory and taken to the
side it's very quick to assemble because
of its lightness but then can be married
with a concrete to make it more stable
to be able to build higher and unware
again all the effort
placed in those initial stages of design
that then will make the construction
happen in a much more controlled and
with much more quality than we see today
and and of course thinking about you
know the diversity and the flexibility
of these systems to produce the series
so I would just want to finish by saying
that today talking from an architect's
point of view we have the knowledge we
have the tools we have the resources to
build a much better and much cheaper and
it is going to require a lot of the
stakeholders to come together and share
the risk and I'm talking of course about
policymakers and governments I'm talking
about constructors and developers and
architects and engineers and users and
and the technology can help in a way to
achieve that but there are many other
factors and and we will need to be very
open to testing and to experimenting a
little bit because if not we will
continue to do things as we've been
doing up to now thank you very much
[Applause]